aujourd'hui on commence par une petite
question comment s'appelle cette actrice
française qui joue dans le dernier James
Bond au côté de Daniel Craig facile
Laura non non c'est pas Laura
je réfléchis je réfléchis je réfléchis
je réfléchis
Eva ne sait c'est un trou de mémoire ça
arrive à tout le monde alors d'où
viennent-ils comment se crustule je vous
explique tout ça aujourd'hui attention
au trou
avant de vous expliquer ce qui se passe
dans notre cerveau quand nous avons un
trou de mémoire rapport rapidement
comment elles fonctionnent cette mémoire
j'espère qu'il va s'en souvenir
la mémoire est une fonction de notre
cerveau qui nous permet de capturer de
conserver et de restituer une
information lorsqu’un souvenir se fixe
dans notre mémoire une image une scène
un mot un son une odeur on dit qu'il se
consolide
à ce moment là des signaux électriques
passent d'un neurone à l'autre un réseau
neuronal se dessine c'est une sorte de
route qui peut relier plusieurs zones de
notre cerveau quand on cherche à
restituer un souvenir on active ce
réseau les neurones se réveillent et se
réactivent entre eux seulement parfois
il arrive que ça bug c'est le cas
lorsqu'on est victime d'un trou de
mémoire
le nom de l'actrice vous l'avez toujours
pas ça y est ça y est Adèle
Exarchopoulos non on était déjà
la mémoire je devrais plutôt dire les
mémoires les scientifiques ont
distinguent cinq situés dans différentes
zones du cerveau on distingue d'abord la
mémoire de travail elle se trouve ici
c'est celle que l'on sollicite pour
retenir momentanément une information
elle ne reste pas très longtemps juste
le temps d'accomplir la tâche par
exemple
à nouveau numéro de téléphone que l'on
va composer une minute plus tard -
parfois on est généralement incapable de
s'en souvenir mais dans ce cas précis il
ne s'agit pas d'un trou de mémoire car
votre cerveau n'a pas stocké cette
information on parle de trou de mémoire
quand l'information a été consolidée
dans la mémoire à long terme qui se
trouve précisément là dans l'hippocampe
ce petit organe situé au cœur de notre
cerveau agit comme un véritable chef
d'orchestre les signaux électriques
partent d'ici vers les neurones pour
imprimer et donc stocker nos souvenirs
on distingue quatre mémoires à long
terme l'une d'elles sert à stocker
toutes nos connaissances générales les
tables de multiplication parier la
capitale de la France c'est la mémoire
sémantique ensuite il y a celle qui
emmagasine les événements passés de
notre vie un examen la naissance de nos
enfants un voyage c'est la mémoire
épisodique elle est liée à nos émotions
la mémoire procédurale elle nous permet
de faire du vélo sans avoir à se poser
de questions enfin nous possédons une
mémoire perceptive c'est la mémoire de
nos sens grâce à elle on se souvient des
visages des bruits des odeurs c'est la
fameuse madeleine de Proust
j'adore les madeleines
Lisa Lorena je sens que je brûle et
maintenant que vous êtes incollables sur
le fonctionnement de la mémoire je vous
explique ce qui se passe lorsque vous
êtes victime d'un trou de mémoire
contrairement au numéro de téléphone qui
n'a pas été stocké dans le cerveau les
informations qui nous échappent ont été
enregistrés dans l'une de nos mémoires à
long terme elles sont donc bien
présentes ici mais pour différentes
raisons on éprouve des difficultés à les
retrouver le meilleur exemple c'est le
nom de cette comédienne que l'on ne
retrouve pas en visualise son visage on
entend sa voix il est stocké quelque
part dans notre mémoire mais rien à
faire il ne veut pas sortir l'oubli peut
durer quelques secondes plusieurs
minutes ou même se prolonger durant des
heures les scientifiques ont baptisé ce
phénomène très intrigant total Tod type
of the Tang littéralement le au bout de
la langue les spécialistes de la mémoire
pensent que ce bug correspondrait à une
difficulté d'accès à l'information plus
qu'un véritable problème de mémoire
notre cerveau aurait parfaitement
identifié l'information recherche le nom
de la célébrité mais il ne parviendrait
pas à obtenir sa formulation sonore
alors que faire quand ça vous arrive je
vous rassure il existe des astuces pour
tenter de faire remonter l'information à
la surface par exemple rechercher des
éléments de contexte se rappeler le
passage d'un film pour retrouver le nom
de l'actrice ou parcourir l'alphabet
pour mettre le doigt sur la première
lettre de son prénom c'est ce que je
fais s'il s'agit d'un titre de chanson
on peut aussi fredonner l'air pour le
retrouver
la Macarena bingo mais ça ne marche pas
à tous les coups dans ce cas il est
inutile de s'acharner il n'est pas rare
que le mot mystère resurgit au bout de
deux ou trois heures alors qu'on est
complètement passé à autre chose plus
surprenant les trous de mémoire peuvent
parfois porter sur des actions que nous
effectuons quotidiennement le meilleur
exemple c'est quand on oublie le code de
notre carte bancaire alors c'est comme
moi votre carte bancaire a déjà été
avalée voici deux petites astuces qui
vous éviteront un nouveau déboires
rendez la pratique de votre code plus
consciente par exemple énoncer les
chiffres dans votre tête lorsque vous
les composez dans votre tête pas à haute
voix ou bien associer les chiffres de
votre code à d'autres connaissances déjà
bien ancrées dans votre mémoire par
exemple pour le code 1 3 7 5 13 75
pensez au département Bouches-du-Rhône
Paris en plus il faut se souvenir des
départements là c'est pas gagné
il y a un sujet qui revient fréquemment
on entend souvent dire que l'abus
d'alcool peut entraîner une perte de
mémoire c'est le fameux blackout en fait
c'est un abus de langage alors bien sûr
après une soirée trop arrosée on peut
avoir du mal à se souvenir de ce que
l'on a fait la veille ça n'a rien de
glorieux mais ce n'est pas la mémoire
qui fait défaut c'est seulement
l'absorption d'alcool qui empêche la
formation de nouveaux souvenirs je
m'explique lorsqu'une information est
captée par notre cerveau celle-ci va
d'abord être intégrée dans la mémoire de
travail la mémoire à court terme pour
être enregistré l'information doit être
transférée dans la mémoire à long terme
c'est ici que l'alcool produit son effet
consommé à l'excès il empêche le
transfert des informations de la mémoire
de travail à la mémoire à long terme
alors petit bémol tout de même
la consommation excessive d'alcool peut
aussi entraîner de graves intoxications
avec des conséquences parfois incurables
sur le cerveau et sur la mémoire donc
vous connaissez la chanson l'alcool
c'est avec modération alors faut-il
s'inquiéter de ces trous de mémoire pour
certaines personnes chez qui ça arrive
régulièrement c'est une vraie source
d'inquiétude où ai-je mis mes clés mon
porte-monnaie j'oublie tout le temps
rassurez-vous en général quand on est
conscient d'avoir des trous de mémoire
c'est qu'on n'est pas malade les gens
qui souffrent de perte de mémoire
pathologique ne s'en rendent pas compte
dans pratiquement 99% des cas dans le
cas de la maladie d'Alzheimer par
exemple la perte des souvenirs est liée
à la perte de neurones ou de connexion
entre eux contrairement aux sentiments
de mots sur la langue il ne s'agit pas
d'une interférence dans le réseau mais
ne sa dégradation le réseau est
incomplet fragmenté d'ailleurs ces
pertes de mémoire prennent une autre
forme on oublie le chemin pour rentrer à
la maison où l'existence d'un objet
plutôt que son emplacement ou le nom de
ses proches elles sont très
handicapantes car elles rendent le
quotidien beaucoup plus difficile pour
la personne et pour ses proches ça y est
je l'ai Léa Seydoux
deux minutes pour trouver c'est pas trop
tôt j'espère que vous avez apprécié
cette vidéo si vous avez déjà oublié
certains passages vous pouvez toujours
la revoir afin de bien la mémoriser
sinon vous pouvez mettre un pouce bleu
et vous abonner à la chaîne et n'oubliez
pas à très vite chers épicurieuses et
épicurieuses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]